what pushed you to audition for survivor
uh i have watched survivors since season
one episode eight and i've never missed
an episode or a season since then i've
watched every single season multiple
times and i've just it's just been a
huge part of my life like i love to
listen to the podcasts read all the
interviews and it's kind of shaped who i
am today so to finally allow canadians
on the show and to make it on is such a
surreal and exciting experience and i'm
so so lucky
so what does it mean for you to
represent canada
i think for me to represent canada is a
very exciting opportunity because canada
is so patriotic and i truly think it's
the best country in the world and i'm so
proud to be a canadian and also to be a
canadian minority you know i never saw a
lot of indians or muslims on the tv
screen growing up and it made me wonder
you know maybe i'm not part of that
community maybe i'm not celebrated or
embraced and so to be so welcomed by
survivor and have canada so excited it
shows that everybody does belong and
we're all just like each other
even if we look different and i hope
that little kids will be really excited
to see somebody that's like them whether
it's because i'm indian muslim or
canadian
i'm sure they will now we have to admit
though the bar is high this season
because erica took it for canada last
season what kind of pressure does that
add to you while playing the game the
bar is high erica really did super well
on season 41 and coming into the game i
also know that uh there's never been an
indian or a muslim winner and there
hadn't been a canadian winner up until
erica so the pressure is high to perform
on my favorite show of all time so you
know
most people will lose the game but you
better give it your all trying so no
matter what happens you have to give 100
in anything you do
most people there's only one winner
yes
how did you prepare mentally physically
and emotionally for survivor
i've been mentally physically and
emotionally preparing for survivor my
whole life um and even being a
veterinarian is like you use those
skills on a daily basis of a social game
you know you have to get to know
everybody um who's coming into the door
and they have different you know
relationships with their pet some are
very happy because it's a health check
some are very sad because they their pet
may have a terminal illness emotions run
very high and it's a very emotionally
difficult profession to be in and so
when you have to meet everybody where
they are that's all the social
preparation that you need in terms of
physicality i really wanted to learn how
to swim better but all the gyms were
closed because the pandemics so
um you'll have to tune in to find out
how that went but uh you know just kind
of watching the show and you know taking
it easy too and realizing just have fun
like if you overthink it you're gonna
shoot yourself in the foot
okay now your list of pet peeves is
probably my favorite thing i've ever
read let me read it back to you
you noted rudeness
finding feeding seeds to parrots gym
grunters joey from friends the fact that
minnie meets have gelatin and when
people talk bad about pigeons just to
name it
so with such a varying list of pet
peeves are you able to hide when
something annoys you when dealing with
people in general
well yeah for sure i mean it's all about
you know putting on the facade and i got
through all of that school and nobody
knew that i was afraid of dogs so i
think that hiding my pet peeves will be
no problem but for anybody listening out
there do not feed seeds to your parents
okay so now you noted that you did have
a challenging childhood both financially
and emotionally
what would winning survivor mean to you
winning survivor would mean everything
to me because in life i try to you know
have big dreams big aspirations like i
wanted to be an exotic vet and i went to
vet school being afraid of dogs so i
pushed through that and then a very
small number become exotic animal
specialist and i put my mind to that
goal and so survivor was the next goal
and so accomplishing my dreams is always
something that's very important to me
because i'm very internally competitive
i'm the hardest person on myself
and also being able to do that coming
from a very challenging childhood
really i hope that shows people you can
rise above your trauma you can learn and
grow and
you can't control everything around you
but
you can hopefully have some empowerment
to do the best that you can
very well said now i know you can't give
much away but there are two other people
representing canada this season
if you're able to say anything about
were you able to work together
i'm not sure tread lightly i think it's
going to be great if people tune in and
find out because surprises are always
better but we of course love to see
canadians on a platform like this and i
hope that everybody makes canada proud
now as a superfan as someone who has
watched it all these years i imagine the
first time you saw jeff in real life it
was a moment can you describe that to me
and did he surprise you in any way
yeah jeff's been like a second father on
the screen for 20 years so this walk
onto that beach and see him um it was so
surreal so exciting he has such a warm
presence and it also prepared me for my
first blind side of the season being
that he had that pandemic haircut and i
loved it
if you could describe this season in
three words what would it be
i'm gonna say monster
exciting and fun